réaliser toutes ses courses alimentaires
au même endroit est devenu une habitude
pour les bressans un réflexe eux dictée
par la grande distribution
pas moins de six supermarchés sont
présents dans un périmètre de 10 km mais
un autre acteur veut tenir sa part du
gâteau avec un aménagement de
stationnement et son service il ya un
grand débat donc entre ceux qui sont
contents d'avoir une main ce serait
spécialisé d'avoir des magasins en plus
notamment pour lutter contre l'évasion
commerciale des gens qui partent sur
chalon sur saône mais des grandes
inquiétudes au sida par des commerçants
locaux et les maires des différentes
communes du secteur
voilà dix ans que le groupe français
souhaite implanter une grande surface
dans cette zone située à l'entrée de la
commune de branche depuis 2010 trois
demandes ont été acceptées et aussitôt
rejetée par la commission départementale
d'aménagement commercial la cause c'est
énième enseigne alimentaire drainerait
moins de clients au centre bourg avec
une boucherie une super a été même de
boulangerie branche dispose encore de
commerce de proximité
défendu par les habitants
on est dans une grande surface et on
achète 90% de
le village vient d'être restauré il est
récent quoi alors donc faut déjà
préserver le petit commerce de proximité
avant déjà de passer encore à une grande
structure
on a déjà ce qu'il faut je pense à peut
s'interroger sur la nécessité savoir si
ça va déplacer les emplois où ça va
réellement créés il reste en tout cas
quelques heures à la commission
départementale pour répondre à ces
interrogations et mettre ou non un
quatrième avis négatif à la demande
d'extension de cette surface commerciale